uh we want to hopefully be done
with this question of is the former
president donald trump going to be able
to hide records phone records and other
records
from the lead up to
and the immediate aftermath of the
january's twenties uh january 6 2021
trump riots the supreme court is now
rejecting donald trump's bid
to hide the riot records is this finally
going to be the end
i really hope so first of all remember
the context this is about riot records
being provided to the january 6th house
committee uh that is investigating the
trump riots abc news or cbs news rather
reports the supreme court on tuesday
turned away
former president donald trump's legal
fight with the white house with the
house select committee investigating the
january 6th assault on the u.s capitol
bringing an end we can only hope
bringing an end to the former
president's quest to stop investigators
from accessing reams of documents from
his final weeks in the white house trump
asked the supreme court in december to
take up his appeal of a decision from
the federal appeals court in washington
d.c
which rejected his efforts to shield the
documents from lawmakers and found trump
provided quote no basis for it to
override president biden's decision
not to uphold his pres predecessor's
claim of executive privilege over the
records in rejecting the former
president's request the decision from
the u.s court of appeals for the
district of columbia circuit remains in
place
in addition to asking the supreme court
to review the lower court's decision
trump requested the justices to stop the
transfer of records from the national
archives to house investigators they
declined to do so last month and the
select committee received more than 700
pages of records sought by the panel
earlier this month so is this finally
the end i really hope so because i am so
sick of this he was president
those are our records these are not
trump's documents to control these are
our records and they should go to the
committee investigating this and of
course
you are innocent until proven guilty
trump has not been charged with anything
he gets an opportunity for all of that
stuff
in a colloquial setting like this which
is not a court of law this is just a
show
one would naturally wonder
why would you be so anxious for those
records not to become public
if you have nothing to hide now there
are two explanations and i want to be
fair one explanation is he has something
to hide that's a completely reasonable
colloquial explanation we might all come
to without saying that means he is
legally guilty of anything he just he
has stuff to hide fine
the other one and it could be this
is that it's a really effective legal
strategy
you always push back and you always
obstruct everything even really simple
requests uncontroversial requests even
if later it'll be revealed there was no
criminal wrongdoing there or whatever
and that makes it harder to figure out
when is trump really being sketchy and
really has something to hide and what i
mean by that is imagine that there were
10 requests made of donald trump and
trump's really only concerned about one
of those requests and that's the only
one that he fights you're you're
telegraphing
where investigators should really be
paying attention you're signaling where
is the wrongdoing really hidden
if there are 10 requests made and you're
only worried about one of them
but you try to obstruct all 10 you are
making it more difficult to determine
which of these 10 things should we
really be focusing on and so i think
that that it's completely plausible that
that's just the legal strategy here and
that's why donald trump is doing this in
terms of trump's willingness to
put records out there remember that he
was just about to publish those tax
returns back in 2015
and then 2016 as soon as the irs audit
was done
and we never got those tax
tax records so we know he never has any
intention of publishing anything last
thought
imagine being an adult
and seeing trump's behavior forget about
during his presidency but just over the
last year since he's been out of office
and still being impressed with him and
thinking that he's an alpha and thinking
that he's smart and a good business
person and a good decision maker it says
almost more about the people that still
support the guy
than it does about trump himself
send me your thoughts you can find us on
facebook at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow
after this break we're going to hear
from merrick garland and much more